buts avec les sénateurs du jour il est
élu du vaucluse siège dans le groupe des
républicains le président donc la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat bonjour à l'année pour jouer merci
merci d'être avec nous ce matin on va
bien sûr parler de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 1 qui
arrive dans l'hémicycle cet après midi
mais d'abord ce tremblement de terre 1
il était presque midi hier quand un fort
séisme a été ressenti dans le sud est de
la france l'épicentre du séisme se
trouve à montélimar le récit et les
dernières informations avec flora
sauvage la secousse d'une magnitude de
5,4 sur l'échelle de richter n'a duré
que quelques secondes peu avant midi
hier près de montélimar dans la drôme
mais elle a fait de nombreux dégâts dans
la commune du teil en ardèche
quatre personnes ont été blessées dont
une grièvement une trentaine d'habitants
ont été hébergés dans un gymnase pour la
nuit
la maison s'est déplacé deux ans m de
chaque côté et à premier abord
j'ai pensé j'ai cru que c'était le gars
qui avait exposé l'épicentre du séisme
se trouve à une dizaine de kilomètres de
la centrale nucléaire de cruas en
ardèche et à une trentaine de kilomètres
du site de tricastin dans la drôme
selon l' agence de sûreté nucléaire
aucun dégât apparent n'a été constatée
sur le site de cruas en ardèche le seuil
6000 vibratoire a déclenché une alarme
sur un seul des cinq capteurs présents
sur le site
conformément à la procédure de sécurité
et de précaution établi par l'opérateur
un arrêt des réacteurs surviendra dans
les prochaines heures
l'arrêt des réacteurs de la centrale de
cruas devrait durer plusieurs jours
le réseau sortir du nucléaire rappelle
que la magnitude du séisme qui s'est
produit hier était supérieure aux
séismes majoré de sécurité pour lesquels
les centrale du tricastin et du cruas
ont été construites alors et non votre
département du vaucluse a également été
touchée vous étiez d'ailleurs comment ça
a été ressenti ce tremblement le
département de vaucluse n'a pas été
touché directement puisque c'est un
drôme ardèche
nous sommes plus au sud à une
cinquantaine de km au sud
par contre nous l'avons ressenti entendu
oui
nous étions dans les manifestations du
11 novembre à sorgues et c'est vrai
qu'on l'a entendu tout au moins ressenti
non on n'a pas senti la terre trembler
on avait un bruit assez spécifique quand
même qu'on reconnaît assez facilement
deux centrales nucléaires sont situés
dans la zone du séisme celles du
tricastin et celle de cruas en ardèche
qui est d'ailleurs à l'arrêt par
précaution pour faire un audit
approfondi alors edf veut rassurant on
dit qu'il n'ya pas de risque mais est ce
que quand même ça pose une fois de plus
la question de la sécurité de ses
centrales nucléaires
très probablement sauf que les
sismologues les spécialistes en
tremblement de terre disent que nous ne
sommes pas à ce niveau-là
au niveau de tricastin et de cruas dans
une zone de tremblement de terre c'était
exceptionnel donc a priori d'après ce
que dit edf n'y a pas de danger grave et
immédiat pour l'ensemble de la
population et donc si l'on arrêté ils
disent que c'est un arrêt par pas
caution faux attendent maintenant les
résultats des enquêtes qu'ils vont mener
sur le sujet tricastin n'ayant pas été
directement touchée quand même mais pas
plus d'inquiétude que cela selon vous
sur l'essence sur sept centrales
nucléaires
pour l'instant non à part leur
vieillissement autre sujet que cette
marche pour dire stop à l'islamophobie
qui a rassemblé plus de dix mille
personnes à paris il ya une polémique
après cette marche sur cette étoile
jaune porté par certains manifestants
dont une petite fille qu'on a vu en
photo a collé à côté de votre collègue
la sénatrice écologiste
esther quel était ce votre sentiment en
voyant cette photo mais au départ quand
on la voit comme ça avoir une étoile
jaune ça évoque beaucoup de choses du
passé et beaucoup de choses
inadmissibles qui sont passés dans le
passé
après quand on regarde bien mais enfin
avoir une analyse fine c'était pas une
étoile à six branches mais l'étoile à
cinq branches
donc il y avait probablement de la part
des organisateurs une volonté de
rattacher d'islamophobie à ce qui s'est
passé dans le passé au niveau de
l'allemagne nazie et puis en même temps
une volonté de ne pas trop se rapprocher
en mettant sa branche plutôt qu 6 mais
il n'empêche que ce qui rocks qui est
retenu aujourd'hui c'est l'image du
passé c'est cette volonté de faire en
sorte que l'ensemble de des musulmans
sont considéré en france comme les juifs
étaient considérés du temps d'hitler en
allemagne et donc c'est extrêmement
choquant parce que monsieur macron
monsieur hollande monsieur sarkozy ne
sont pas monsieur hitler loin de là les
musulmans sont considérés comme des
citoyens normaux
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
est donc nécessaire de revenir à plus de
raison par ce symbole qui a été mis sur
certains 28 ans autre question
d'actualité aujourd'hui c'est bruno
retailleau et xavier bertrand qui seront
reçus par le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner sur leur proposition
d'interdire les listes communautaire est
ce que vous êtes favorable oui oui on
peut remarquer d'abord que et bruno
retailleau et il avait bertrand qui sont
favorables à l'interdiction des jeux
communautaires n'ont pas se font partie
de courant un peu différent au sein de
ce qu'on appelle la droite
oui tout à fait lui au sein de ce qu'on
appelle la droite
donc s'ils sont d'accord sur ce sujet
c'est bien parce qu'il existe quand même
un problème de communautarisme sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et il
est important de faire respecter la
laïcité d'abord ce qu'il nous semble
être quelque chose qui marque quand même
la france au niveau international peu de
pays sont autant laïque que la france
tout en admettant l'ensemble des
religions possible donc il est
nécessaire de garder ce point de laïcité
qui me semble être le plus importante
est d'empêcher que le communal
communautarisme en tant que tel
devienne un parti politique qui pourrait
dans l'avenir mettre en danger la
démocratie
vous êtes un bout de ligne on pose est
est-ce que finalement la droite ne met
pas en avant ce sujet parce que c'est le
seul sujet sur lequel j'ai pas dit que
lille va j'ai pas dis donnio posé deux
lignes différentes au sein d'un même
droite et je pense que l'honneur de la
droite c'est justement de d'admettre des
citoyens qui sur certains sujets peuvent
avoir des différences importantes dont
pour la droite c'est bien de parler de
ce sujet contre des noms ne se le sujet
sûrement pas il ya le plfss il y tenait
il ya la sécurisation
il ya beaucoup de sujets justement
puisque le sénat débute aujourd'hui
l'examen de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale on en
parle avec notre journaliste
parlementaire alex course à relais
bonjour rien de bon jour alain milon
congio et alex on va parler de ce projet
doit ce budget 2020 qui creuse pas le
trou de la sécu et oui on peut dire que
cette année le gouvernement a plombé les
comptes de la sécurité sociale
regardez dans cette infographie
l'évolution du budget de la sécu depuis
l'élection d' emmanuel macron en 2018 ça
avait plutôt bien commencé avec un
déficit à 4 milliards d'euros en 2019 le
trou de la sécu étaient quasiment
résorbées
et puis cette année patatras un déficit
de 5,5 milliards d'euros prévus pour
alors comment expliquer cette situation
eh bien le mouvement des gilet jaune est
passé par là et oui les mesures en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat vont coûter 2
7 milliards d'euros à la sécurité
sociale
le problème c'est que l'état ne veut pas
compenser ces mesures au budget de la
sécurité sociale alors qu'elles relèvent
normalement du budget de l'état les
sénateurs dans le débat ont donc
rétablir les compensations de l'état
et puis autre point important dans ce
débat le budget de l'hôpital pour 2020
hélas pour les sénateurs de droite comme
de gauche le compte n'y est pas tout
simplement parce que le gouvernement ne
consacre pas assez de moyens à l'hôpital
écoutez le sénateur socialiste yves
daudigny avec une progression des
dépenses pour l'hôpital fixée
virgule 1 aucune réponse sérieuse aux
qu'un début de solution ne peuvent être
apportées alors ceci d'autant plus que
la ministre a indiqué appelant hôpital
qui serait donc présenté au courant du
mois de novembre
après la manifestation de la semaine
prochaine avec des moyens pose la
question de l'utilité de débattent dans
le plfss si dans le même temps une autre
loi de financement biz ou un plfss
rectificatif doit être présentée il ya
un autre point qui va être intéressant
dans ce débat du budget de la sécu c'est
celui sur les retraites puisque les
sénateurs de droite sont favorables à un
recul à 64 ans de l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite noté que dans ce budget le
gouvernement a également prévu un quasi
gel des pensions de retraite supérieures
à 2000 euros et pour les sénateurs c'est
non ils vont donc rétablir une hausse de
1% de ses pensions sur le niveau de la
hausse des prix tout comme les
prestations familiales qui avait été
gelé par le gouvernement donc le débat
s'annonce tendu entre les sénateurs et
le gouvernement
merci beaucoup alex alain milon de
débats s'annoncent tendues entre
sénateurs et gouvernement dans ce texte
il met toute la semaine probablement ça
a été dit toute la semaine je crois en
effet mais je voudrais revenir sur ce
que sur ce qui a été présenté
quand on dit 1 le budget premier budget
de ces crises sociales de monsieur
macron 2018 déficitaire de -1 milliard
des poussières 800 millions comme de
poussière c'est pas le plfss de monsieur
macron c'est quand même le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
le dernier présenté par monsieur
hollande et marisol touraine qui avait
d'ailleurs été présentée à léquilibre un
équilibre à moins-18 ou 1,9 c'est pas
tout à fait un équilibre le premier ep
fss de monsieur macron c'est le 2019
et c'est vrai qu'il avait été présenté
avec un déficit de 200 millions
seulement
sauf qu'au bout du compte il n'est pas
200 millions mais à moins 5 4 milliards
de déficit
c'est assez considérable et c'est dur
aux mesures gilet jaune qui ont été
décidées par le gouvernement et qui a
d'ailleurs qui ont d'ailleurs été votée
par l'assemblée nationale et par le
sénat notamment le taux réduit est donc
nous en arrivons à ce 2020 ou là il est
présenté on est en déficit de - 5 1
milliards d'euros ce qui est un déficit
considérable dire qu'on revient sur des
déficits antérieurs à certains de paix
aient l'effet cesse de la mandature de
monsieur hollande
mais ce déficit est dû pour près de 3
milliards à des décisions prises par le
gouvernement sur des exonérations et c
est pour près de 2 milliards un peu
moins faut pas retenir les chiffres
exactement et qui sont dus à une
augmentation de la masse salariale
donc il ya deux sujets importants le
sujet de la compensation des décisions
prises par le gouvernement
mais vous dites clairement l'état fait
payer à la sécu les marges et les gens à
l'aise tout à fait tout à fait c est qu
qui payent une partie de ces mesures
le reste c'est le budget d'état et la
dette puisque en fait l'ensemble des
mesures jeunes sont payés par parler par
la dette
donc c'est quand même très inquiétant
surtout pour la sécurité sociale pour
vous ça met en danger l'indépendance
financière de la sécu sont 28
complètement complètement mais déjà
depuis un bon moment
depuis que l'état a décidé par exemple
de supprimer les cotisations salariales
au bénéfice de la csg le siège étant un
impôt est donc pas une contribution
sociale malgré son nom c'est bercy qui
contrôle et donc on voit que
progressivement les impôts prennent le
dessus sur les cotisations donc
progressivement la gestion d'un sécurité
sociale qui était une gestion paritaire
à la suite de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et du comité national de la
révolte à la révolution de la résistance
et elle a maintenant on arrive à un
système que j'ai appelé il ya deux ans
en arrière d'un terme qui a beaucoup de
succès actuellement c'est une paire 6 à
sion du système c'est à dire c'est bercy
qui contrôle l'ensemble progressivement
l'ensemble de ces crises sociales et
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas dit on
n'a pas demandé aux français s'ils
étaient d'accord ou pas sur ce système
je pense que chaque chaque système a ses
qualités ses défauts
moi je ne suis pas d'accord pour qu'on
supprime le système paritaire tel qu'il
avait été fait et par marcel et par
monsieur cash a réparé
général de gaulle mais pourquoi pas mais
enfin leur faut demander à ce moment là
aux françaises et aux français s'ils
sont d'accord
l'autre sujet c'est l'hôpital en pleine
crise des hôpitaux y aura une grande
manifestation le 14 jeudi
en quoi ce budget n'est pas à la hauteur
de la crise est ce que dit l'opposition
de droite
ce budget est budget antérieur n'était
ne sont pas à la hauteur de la crise
parce que progressivement à la suite des
honda hm
1 les objectifs nationaux de dépenses
d'assurance maladie qui ont été mis du
temps la mandature de monsieur hollande
7% et depuis monsieur macron à 2 3 ou
2,1 pour cette année pour cent
d'augmentation des dépenses
on sait que l'augmentation
l'augmentation tendancielle est à plus
de 4 plus de 4,5 plus de 4 plus tôt
entre 4 et 4,5 donc en bref augmenter
ses dépenses de santé jeu il faut et à
la fois monté les dépenses de santé est
à la fois trouver des ressources pour
augmenter ses dépenses de santé
quand on dit qu'à une augmentation
tendancielle de l'ondam est de 4 ça veut
dire qu'il faut trouver 8 milliards la
dépense est en moyenne de 200 milliards
4,2 dont dame c'est huit milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires accordés ce qui
est considérable est ce qu'on ne trouve
pas d'une année sur l'autre parce que
c'est 8 milliard d'une année sur l'autre
donc il faut à la fois faire des mesures
de restriction ou des mesures
d'organisation pour avoir mois de
dépenses en particulier dans tout ce qui
est des dépenses redondantes ou
récurrentes comme des dépenses
d'imagerie médicale ou de biologie et
puis dans le même temps en faisant
cesser ces mesures prendre des
ressources nouvelles là où elle se
trouve
il y a
le gouvernement pas des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui c'est vrai qu'ils
font des ressources supplémentaires mais
il n'ya pas que laboratoires
pharmaceutiques ya par exemple les
organismes complémentaires d'assurance
maladie mais le n est besoin doit
annoncer un plan un nouveau plan hôpital
dans les semaines à venir est ce que
pour vous ce plan il doit contenir des
mesures financières immédiates est ce
qu'il faut par exemple une enveloppe
telle qu'elle a été donné au gilet jaune
ben e ce serait peut-être insuffisant
même enveloppe globale de jeunes je
crois que c'est près de 11 milliards
pour pour l'hôpital ce serait peut-être
insuffisant actuellement puisque il
manque de personnel il manque
d'investissement il manque de matériel
elle l'a dit là dans le jdd
je sais pas si vous avez vous avez
sûrement regardé cette interview très
intéressante très intéressante parce que
les mesures proposées sont intéressantes
et très intéressante parce que les
mesures proposées ne font pas partie du
plfss que nous sommes en train de voter
qui sera donc absolument obsolète dès
que madame blizzard aura fait ses
annonces
donc la nécessité quand même de de dire
au gouvernement et pas à la miss mutuel
à négocier tous avec le gouvernement
mais de dire au gouvernement que quand
il fait ce genre d'annoncé qu'il le
fasse dans le cadre de son père fss et
pas en dehors du préfet c'est son
considérant que le parlement ne sert à
rien la mini c'est ce que disent tous
tous les parlementaires on nous fait
voter un budget qui sera obsolète c'est
le premier point les mesures annoncées
par mme buzyn dans le cadre des mesures
d'hôpital sont extrêmement intéressants
dont une en particulier je vais
apprendre parce qu elles mais elles me
concernent directement
il y à 7 8 ans en arrière avec le
sénateur socialiste de bretagne monsieur
ne nous revient pas là jacques et jacky
le menn nous avions proposé la
suppression des investissements
immobiliers de l'hôpital pris en charge
par la santé ces investissements
immobiliers pour l'éducation nationale
par exemple l'éducation nationale ne
paye pas les investissements mobiliers
des écoles maternelles primaires des
collèges des lycées ou des universités
il a cité un petit peu c'est l'état qui
prend en charge les villes et communes
et c'est donc là c'est la santé et la
sécurité sociale qui prend en charge les
investissements immobiliers et avec
jacky le menn nous avions dit
on fait en sorte que ces investissements
immobiliers soir pris en charge par
l'état ou par la caisse des dépôts et
consignations qui a largement les moyens
ou par une banque sanitaire
d'investissement ou par l'état lui-même
et j'ai vu que bercy n'étaient pas
d'accord c'est quand même une enveloppe
de près de 30 milliards d'euros ce qui
paraît mince je suis d'accord enfin au
moment de la mise en place des
différents textes sur la sncf des dettes
ont été pris en charge par l'état
pourquoi pas au niveau de la santé le
temps file alain milon je vois une tente
sur un autre point qui se fait lfss et
la droite sénatoriale qui a adopté un
amendement vous en commissions relevant
progressivement l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans est ce que pour vous
c'est la seule solution non non non mais
encore une fois posés chaque année final
donc voir le propose parce que nous nous
considérons que la mesure paramétrique
est nécessaire pour permettre de
d'assurer à l'ensemble nos concitoyens
retraités une retraite décente et
durable donc la mesure paramétrique nous
semble nécessaire
il ya d'autres mesures qui nous semble
nécessaire ce que nous constatons c'est
les hésitations du gouvernement encore
dernièrement entre le ministre chargé la
retraite ceux de le voir et le premier
ministre ya eu des désaccords il ya une
semaine à peine et les désaccords sont
de plus en plus important est de plus en
plus nombreux or il est évident qu'il ya
urgence à modifier le système de
retraite
on voit bien quand on regarde la caisse
des caisses de retraite le fonds de
solidarité vieillesse il ya un déficit
qui devient considérable qui est
prévisible à 2023
à moins 6 milliards 5 ce qui est pas une
petite somme encore une fois donc vous
dites le gouvernement ne pourra pas se
contenter de sa réforme systémique il
faudra prendre des mesures paramétrique
il faudra que le gouvernement mette en
place une réforme systémique globale ce
qui ne semble pas être le cas non plus
maintenant et une réforme paramétrique
sinon dans quelques années on sera
obligé de revenir dessus en français
qu'il ira au bout sur sa grande réforme
des retraites annoncé cette fameuse
réforme systémique
je pense que c'est souhaitable je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il le puisse
c'est à dire pourquoi c'est en fait par
la rue non pas par le temps par le temps
par les motards et c'est vrai que ça me
semble être trop temps allez on va
changer de sujet tous les jours on va
prendre on se rend dans une rédaction
locale aujourd'hui direction mais se
retrouver nos partenaires du républicain
lorrain bonjour philippe marc vous
journaliste au républicain lorrain le
républicain lorrain qui dans son édition
de ce matin consacre sa double page
d'ouverture au sujet de la biodiversité
pourquoi ce choix bah pour plusieurs
raisons on fait d'abord parce que c'est
un sujet particulièrement dans l'air du
temps est évidemment surtout à l
approche des élections municipales où
tous les candidats font de
l'environnement une priorité dans leur
dans leur profession de foi mais ensuite
parce que c'est une thématique qui a
toujours intéressé mais ce vous rappeler
que mais c'est la ville de jean marie
pelt qui est le pionnier de l'écologie
urbaine et puis enfin surtout ce qui a
motivé ce dossier c'est que justement où
metz vient de décrocher le trophée de
meilleur grandes villes pour la
biodiversité
c'est un trophée qui est décerné par des
experts du centre technique national
plante et cité et de l' agence française
pour la biodiversité la métropole de
lyon a obtenu le titre de capitale de la
biodiversité qu'est ce qui fait que metz
a remporté justement ce titre de
meilleure ville devant un renne lille
dijon ou encore saint paul à la réunion
alors il ya sans doute plusieurs choses
qui ont séduit le jury mais
particulièrement le fait que metz a
réalisé une étude très précise qui
détaillent le rôle des arbres en ville
et les services qu'ils rendent et de
cette étude il ressort qu'il ne faut par
exemple pas planter le même arbre au
bord d'une route ou en zone piétonne
l'homme devra à capter le carbone alors
que l'autre est chargée de réguler la
température
et puis à toutes ces initiatives que
metz a mis en place ou projettent c'est
notamment l'avis de créer un parcours
fraîcheur le projet de planter vingt
mille nouveaux arbres d'ici à 2030
alors l'idée d'implanter des espèces qui
s'adapte aux modifications climatiques
et du coup en lorraine on commença à
parler de l'arrivée du micocoulier de
provence ou alors des sapins d'espagne
ou du colorado réchauffement climatique
oblige et après à la gestion d'une forêt
proche du centre ville qui a beaucoup
plu aussi aux jurys parce qu'elle joue
un rôle de véritable poumon vert
et puis là plusieurs initiatives qui
vont de l'écopâturage aux jardins
partagés en passant par la renaturation
des berges de la cei qui est un petit
cours d'eau qui traverse le centre ville
et à tout ça il ya une formule d'une
d'une élue municipale qui résume très
bien la situation je la cite elle dit
ces initiatives ne régleront pas le
problème du réchauffement climatique
mais elles font que ces villes reste
vivable pour ceux qui habitent et on
philippe marc ce dossier sur la
biodiversité on l'a dit c'est une double
page 1 dans votre journal mais ce n'est
pas là une puisque vous avez privilégié
à un autre sujet en une c'est le séisme
en ardèche qui à proximité de plusieurs
centrales nucléaires pourquoi vous avez
fait ce choix bah tout simplement parce
que la lorraine c'est une terre de
nucléaire aussi on à l'implantation
d'une des plus anciennes centrales de
france la centrale de cattenom et
surtout en lorraine on a le projet
national de la future implantation du
des déchets laissés fameux déchets du
nucléaire dont on sait que faire et qui
vont être enfouis très prochainement en
lorraine donc forcément c'est un sujet
très très con cernant chez nous merci
beaucoup merci philippe marquet
républicain lorrain d'avoir été en
direct avec nous ce matin avant de
passer à la rue de presse de votre
département alain milon on parlait
d'agnès busan sur l'hôpital et les
médecins être auditionné cet après midi
par le sénat par la commission d'
enquête sur l'incendié de l'usiné
lubrizol année ce but on se veut
rassurant tant sur les conséquences
sanitaires de cet incendie est ce que
vous y croyez
oui oui ou non je pense que la ministre
fait son travail qu'elles vous donnent
qu'elle donne à l'ensemble de la
population les résultats des analyses
qui sont faites par différentes
il faudra laboratoire différentes
agences et que a priori ces analyses
sont assez rassurantes
le problème n'est pas tellement
maintenant sur sur les effets
secondaires parce que ils existeront
mais seront mineurs très probablement le
problème est plus et c'est d'ailleurs la
mission de 2,2
de cette mission de banque est de savoir
comment installer les usines seveso sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
sachant qu'au départ a été installé à
l'extérieur des villes mais qui sait les
villes qu'ils ont progressivement
rattrapé moi dans ma vie j'ai deux
usines ses réseaux c'est vrai que au
départ elle était installée très loin de
la ville et que la ville progressivement
s'étendant à les a rattrapés oui oui
tout à fait et savoir comment installer
des seveso et peut-être aussi comme ça
c'est fait vous chez moi un poteau vie
nationale
comment installer des produits dangereux
loin les uns des autres à saumon à la
poudrerie nationale mais les produits
certains produits dangereux sont
assemble d'autres qui pourraient être
dangereux pour les produits dangereux de
sens qui sont plus tôt à bordeaux ou à
périgueux allez on va rester dans votre
département va garder la une
la revue de presse de votre département
du vaucluse avec alex harvey rosen et
oui vaucluse matin qui consacre sa une
aux séismes historiques qui a frappé
hier les départements de la drôme et de
l'ardèche
un séisme de magnitude 5,4 très rare en
france métropolitaine c'est le séisme le
plus fort depuis en france depuis ses 16
dernières années et vaucluse matin
consacre une double page regarder à cet
événement avec un bilan qui est assez
lourd 1 4 blessés dont un blessé grave
des dégâts sur une dizaine de bâtiments
et une centrale nucléaire à l'arrêt
regardez ce témoignage du maire de la
commune du teil où se situe l'épicentre
de ce séisme
selon lui c'est une catastrophe des gens
ont tout perdu l'église du centre ville
est prête à tomber on voit le ciel
depuis l'intérieur
j'étais chez moi quand c'est arrivé j'ai
cru que des bombes tombaient et la
provence 1 revient également sur sa
séance demain ce matin
et oui la provence revient sur le
ressenti de la secousse dans le
département du vaucluse et notamment à
avignon
les pompiers du département du vaucluse
ont ainsi recueilli une cinquantaine
d'appels notamment dans le nord du
département où ce séisme a été ressenti
et de manière très forte d'une
général ce séisme historique a été
ressenti jusque dans les villes de
clermont ferrand et d'annecy merci
beaucoup alex poussard une réaction très
rapide peut-être monsieur le sénateur
donc bien une cinquantaine d'appels sur
avignon sorgues et à 5 km d'avignon ce
procès comme vous nous avez dit que vous
l'aviez aujourd'hui merci merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin dans deux minutes
c'est l'heure de